so report just came in at 3.2 8 million
Americans just apply for unemployment
this is not something we're accustomed
to this is not a number we're used to
having this kind of unemployment but at
the same time I was having a
conversation with a few different guys
in Pat how do you protect yourself
against a loss like this I mean you're
in the insurance business you're in the
anticipation business
what are you doing something like this
but what's the best kind of insurance
for something like this it is in life it
is an auto insurance it isn't you know
homeowners insurance
it isn't cellphone insurance it isn't
any desktop although that stuff is got a
place for it the most important thing
today for time like this is income
protection insurance and income
protection insurance is based on a few
things that you need to do so let me set
that part aside let me give you a
complete different side that we have to
look at look 2001 9/11 happens 2008
market crashes 2020 we have the pandemic
2001 in 2020 have a lot in common
because they're both a Black Swan nobody
could have predicted it 2008 a lot of
experts could have predicted it that's
what big short movie came up so what
would you do at a time like this there's
three different types of people today
the first group are those that are
relying on the stimulus to come I can't
wait for my unemployment and $1,000
check in the $600 a week for 39 weeks
that's awesome I can't wait for this I'm
going to stay home I'm going to catch up
on movies I'm going to do all this other
stuff they're just so glad that the
government's bailing them out the second
group is the one that's like listen I
don't need government's help I'm ok I've
saved money
I already experienced a once a no one I
didn't want to experience it again I
already went through a no wait when I
lost a lot of money the real I told
myself that'll never happen to me again
I don't need the government's bill I'm
gonna be ok I've saved money I've been
preparing for this stuff I want to be
fine then there's a third group of
people that are saying I am being forced
to change and Pat I can't stand it I
don't like where I'm at right now and
the reality of it is we change in two
different ways one is by choice one is
by force many people today are being
forced to change so those of you that
are in the third group or you're saying
I kind of want to make sure this never
happens to me ever again what do I do
let me kind of give you a few things to
be thinking about number one these are
the time when you realize the skill set
of pivoting energy
think whoever knows how to pivot and
adjust they have an edge over everybody
else just know most people are gonna
watch what everybody else is gonna be
doing a few people are gonna be pivoting
adjusting pivoting adjusting with
current times because again we've never
been through this before to pivot and
just that's one skill set it's a mindset
you got along what to do the other part
well economically to talk about the
income protection is knowing what kind
of skills hey today for instance if you
don't know how to zoom you gotta learn
how to zoom if you don't know how to do
webinars you need to learn how to do
webinars if you're not a person that
facetimes a lot you need to learn how to
do face them if you're not somebody on
Facebook or social media or Instagram
that goes live you need to learn how to
do that if you're not a social media
person you need to learn how to do that
if you don't create content you may need
to learn how to do that if you don't
have a service to sell that's not a
physical product today maybe you need to
learn how to sell a service today if
you're not a good salesperson maybe you
need to learn how to sell today because
those skill sets are required today so
when this happens the income protection
the insurance policy for your income
protection is knowing that you know how
to make money when everything is fine
but you also know how to make money when
the economic growth of one hundred
twenty eight months in a row expansion
stops you also know how to make money at
times like this I think that money
mindsets are something that are not
talked about enough because you could go
from wherever you are today to tripling
your income tripling and would your
money mindsets magically change no in
fact we have a lot of people some of
whom are notable well they're in a lot
of financial communities and they have
increased our earnings but they still
obsess over pennies and you look at them
and you say that like that that must be
sad or wow like they're so cheap these
are words that we use but the fact is
that once you figure out how to make
more money and there is a process for
making more money I've been teaching
fifteen years this doesn't just come
along magically you have to engineer
this just as much as you engineer your
income that is why everyone has a
cheap-ass uncle who has a lot of money
but still checks everybody's expenses
when it comes to settling up the tap
everybody okay
that person learned how to make money
but they did not learn the accompanying
skill of changing their money mindset in
general when it comes to money in
America the vast majority of people know
and like frugality that is what they
know that's what they grew up with and
that is what they expect so when I
started talking after years of writing
about money stuff I started writing
about earning more a lot of people did
not like it and they started saying this
seems like a scam cuz earning more to a
lot of people seems like a scam why
because they've been raised with the
money mindset of this is all we have we
should be happy and we better protect it
don't let anybody tax us that's evil Oh
socialism Oh [ __ ] lunatics but they
never think about expanding the size of
the pie okay so when I started talking
about this very uncomfortable it's like
a whole different world view and people
started unsubscribe
they started leaving first and trickles
then in the hordes at that time I had
about 50,000 email subscribers over the
course of the next few years I would
lose approximately 35 to 40,000 of those
subscribers let me say that again in
case you didn't catch it
I had 50,000 subscribers over the course
of the next few years I would lose
approximately 35,000 of those
subscribers do you understand what that
feels like and you understand that at
the time I used an email service
provider that allowed people to write
why they were unsubscribed so every day
I'm getting fifty to a hundred things
that say used to enjoy your stuff but
nowadays I dare ask and that went on for
years how do you think you would feel if
you had actually built something up
where people liked you and you were
enjoying it but then you decided to take
a different turn and a lot of them said
you suck I'm out of here not good it it
really did not feel good but at that
moment I realized a principle and that
principle is my future is bigger than my
past and I truly believe this
I believed that at the time I'd been
writing about I don't know four four or
five years something like that and I
knew that I had decades to work on this
little site I called I will teach you to
be rich and decades to explore all kinds
of stuff I could never even imagine at
the time but I knew that the 35,000
people who were unsubscribing in the
grand scheme were just a drop in the
bucket I think that having that
principle is the one of the only things
that allowed me to keep going because if
I had simply looked at 50,000 going down
every single day I would have given up
but I knew that my future was bigger
than my past and so I see this principle
now applied everywhere I see people who
come and sometimes they see some my
fitness posts and they're like I'm 47 or
I'm 57 is it too late for me fitness
wise they ask the same thing about money
10 times more I'm 50 I didn't start
investing at 22 like that one example in
your book is it too late for me my
answer is it's never too late it's never
too late to stop but we need to be
candid about how much we can achieve I
had something like a 65 year old woman
write me and said I need to make
$100,000 in the next one year and I'm on
a fixed income so I need to make it
through
unfortunately that's not gonna happen
and sometimes we need to hear the candid
truth I had to be very gentle about that
message so you won't make a hundred
thousand dollars off investments in one
year but the second best thing you can
do is to start now because you know what
else can you do you're just gonna give
up no let's start today is never too
late we can adjust what our expectations
are but let's start I think John
sometimes the world has to fall apart
for it to be rebuilt even better
and you know Italy for example is very
dear to my heart I wrote a lot of the 5
a.m. Club in Italy and many countries
around the world we're seeing our
brothers and sisters afflicted with the
kovat 19 virus and people dying and you
know that's always a very sad thing so I
feel that on the other hand I'm a
radical optimist and and you know if you
study history you know that we have to
go through difficult things and I think
I think there are opportunities for us
here I think a lot of people are going
through this and it's refocusing their
priorities I think a lot of people are
going through this and they're realizing
their vulnerabilities I think John this
is a time where we can look at the fear
we might be feeling or the sadness or
the loneliness and rather than pointing
the finger we can look in the mirror and
say what healing must I do and how can I
use this adversity to strengthen
creatives and being so I think there are
clearly sufferings on the planet no
question but I think very much this is
you know leaders are leaders are born
not in times of ease leaders are born in
days of discomfort now we all get to
grow up as leaders and strengthen
ourselves listen as this global pandemic
continues and carries on more and more
and more people are getting trapped in
that feeling of fear that feeling of
scarcity that feeling of oh my gosh will
this ever end will I survive this and
listen it is a scary time and it is a
difficult time and during that then we
must as hard it is as hard as it is
demand something more from ourselves
because it's not normal conditions right
and I know how easy does it yes I know
it's hard and it's normal not normal
condition so I'm just going to bow out
right now but I'm I'm gonna I'm gonna
take a pause err you know I'm gonna
pause my entire life I'm gonna bow out
I'm gonna avoid distract quit like
disappear into my comforts and by the
way I know some people are doing that
and is create this big controversy of
okay
is this you know some battle right now
between you know personal development
spirituality and people talking about
hey you should just be coping with this
and some other people saying hey you
should be moving through with this and
you're hearing this big debate of peace
vs. productivity and those who espouse
productivity and moving ahead and
engaging this as a role model and
summoning the best of who we are
sometimes that's misconstrued as saying
don't cope don't take time you know
don't you know give yourself an
opportunity to rest or recover and
listen I'm here to tell you this is not
a binary conversation of either you rest
and cope or you keep moving ahead and
that's called a false dichotomy right
y'all y'all know I'm talking about
that's a false dichotomy it's not rest
and recover and cope or be productive
focused and move ahead
and confident each day it's not done
either or because real coping is
understanding that you must actively
rest actively recover and actively have
a sense of purpose or mission or things
to do each day to move your life forward
even if it's small little things and so
I just want to point that out because
you know I've never ever ever had so
many people say you know things that
were just so uninformed by either
personal development or psychology or
just general like working with other
people because listen you can be
empathetic right now with other people
like many of you you met you've got
teams you've got people you lead you got
people you serve you've got people who
take care of your family is counting on
you you can absolutely be empathetic and
empowering but what I won't be and I
made this choice it was very hard at
beginning cuz I thought you know what if
I'm still gonna tell people not to
forget their dream if I'm still gonna
tell people yes the world is chaotic but
you know what that means
you've gotta adopt the role model
mindset because a year from now you're
either gonna be proud of how you dealt
with a difficult time in life or you
know you know what I really let myself
go or you know what I really just I quit
or you know what really I just stopped
trying and I I just I kind of hid out I
just had to kind of hit on the couch the
whole time waiting for it to pass now
I'm somebody here who is not against you
being on television serves are you well
I'm not against you sitting and watching
television even though that's becoming
like what a lot of people think about me
that is not what I'm saying at all if
you want to you know have some Netflix
or Hulu or Disney and watch some
television at night no problem and
people say well but Brendon some people
just need a whole weekend to do that I'm
like fine but we're months into this
thing we're months into this thing if
you are on the couch for months at a
time
disengaging not doing things actively to
care for your family care for your
health care for your mission for your
team
it's not healthy and let's not pretend
well they're just coping Brendan I'm
like no no no I listen yes we all have
different styles of coping and I'm the
person that from day one I said
everyone's in a cup with us so
differently because I've been coaching
and training and working with people one
on one for two decades you know a lot of
armchair you know personal develop you
are saying oh well you know just let
people cope their way through this and
we'll all get through and they're very
enabling with poor habits but I'm the
high-performance habits guy I care about
how you're performing for your family
right now because they're watching see
if we don't care about our performance
what are we gonna have during this
pandemic we're gonna have a greater
emotional contagion that is
disassociation that is this engagement
that is those things of avoidance and
seeking like comfort or simple pleasures
at the cost of those difficult actions
to take those small movements each day
to keep moving like forward because
listen
you can have both you can actively
recover rest and cope because listen
every single day I'm still making sure I
do my meditation I'm still making sure I
get a walk in or a meditation and I'm
still working really hard to get those
eight hours of sleep in which is really
hard right now and there's lots of
stress I'm still making sure I'm
focusing on my breath I'm still making
sure that every 50 minutes I get up from
my desk I closed my eyes I bounce in
place I take 10 deep breaths to reset my
eye strain to open up my lungs to move
the link around my body a little bit get
some water I'm still making sure I
talked to friends I'm still making sure
that I have time to kinda like chill
with the book or to watch a show with my
lady Denise who many of you all know so
I'm still yes actively caring for my
health you can and you must actively
care for your energy and your recovery
and your coping to be a high performer
we found that in the world's largest are
you
I performers if you read high forms
habits this chapter to write they
generate energy how they generate energy
by protecting it by making sure that
they're doing things to release the
tension in their life in healthy and
productive ways for those who've been
throwing you know hate at me for asking
people to still believe in their dreams
to not give up on their dreams to
continue each day doing something to
move the needle forward no matter what
it is because listen even if you've
completely gone in that super coping
mechanism or let's say for those who
have really had massive mental health
issues through this crisis even any
decent therapists would say let's still
find some things for you to do each day
sometimes that might be you took a
shower today
sometimes that made me you wash the
dishes you made the bed you remember to
feed the kids it can be simple things so
I'm not asking anybody climb Kilimanjaro
right now I'm saying and don't forget
your dream I'm saying don't forget you
got a mission I'm saying don't retreat
so much into comfort and distraction
that you don't engage what is real right
now and what is real my friends what's
real right now
crisis need people Nietzsche and you can
show up for them that's true
we are being called to serve right now
we're being called to help right now
we're being called to be positive voices
in each other's lives really right now
if you've ever going to demonstrate your
best self why would that not be now
because if you won't do it now what does
that really say about your values in
judgement yes there it should just
challenge I was like you know the
challenges how to make money from your
house during coronavirus challenge and
the reason for it is because if you
could figure out how to make money right
now while this is going on from your
house you'll probably find that after
this is over you can still make money
from your house
so you know the thing here is to try new
things you know that's what I'm doing as
well as sharpen up my pencil and my on
my blade which is now the pencils like
doing things I wasn't doing before like
writing oh I'm about to go to the
gallery and get my guitar start playing
em again you know I'm taking the time to
just do all the things I've been wanting
to do that I just never got a chance to
do but I might try to learn a language
while I'm here
quarantine but you know it's crazy at
the end of the day my life again I keep
saying and it really hasn't changed you
know it's like if you're not prepared to
be quarantined even if there's never a
reason to be quarantined
then it almost seems like your life
might not be together you know I mean
like you should always be prepared to
have a good house that you have that you
could stay in for a couple of weeks if
you have to you should have enough
supplies your frigerators ship before at
least if you're an adult you know and I
was thinking about who was it that's
really panicking the most and if people
that are worried about being employed by
other people like I want can't go to
work I was thinking about the people
that were told yo you got to go to work
even though there's Corona outside like
just some people a week ago I was like
you're still working and they would like
to ain't tell me they told me I still
got to go to work like someone could
tell you got to work go to work even if
there's a disease that could kill you
outside and you know those are the
people that have to worry about them if
this person still gonna pay me you know
how am I gonna earn see when you have
their own independent business I feel
like you make the products that you sell
to to earn so you know no one could
really stop you from selling your
product so as long as you have a product
you know then you could sell it so now
it's about figuring out what your
product is that you could sell and then
being able to just get it delivered
directly to the house now the good thing
about content this content gives you
residual
income so once you make it once it
continues to make money every time it
gets played and you never have to create
it again
that's the kind of money that you can
get just sitting by the pool relaxing
ten years after you did the action
you're not adapting to this new economy
you're truly gonna get left behind
and now it's country let alone the world
people who are not truly prepared to
adapt an economy you're seeing a man
they're like completely losing losing
everything it's crazy you know I feel
like it's it's gonna get even worse with
people that are not truly starting to
adapt and you know just start to
leverage the internet man and I feel
right because we saw this coming when I
was like 18 years old I saw the internet
as such a way to create freedom you know
such a way for me to like just go after
my dreams and you know it's interesting
because like for me not much has changed
I feel like I've always been doing my
where in the world you know I'm building
online businesses so greatest because we
have the freedom wherever we are the
world if you were in Italy right now
what would you do what steps would you
take as a businessman as a businessman I
think I think what I've heard coming on
that too cuz Italy did just shut down
all of its businesses all pharmacies are
open right yeah so it's commercially
closed there's not a lot you can do
right now however they don't shut down
the internet correct so if you're
selling products online then you are
okay if you're selling products that are
subscription-based models learning from
home things drop shipping miles there
outside Italy it's time to start
considering let's say yourself things
that um but you're not using drops
you're beating now then you would
transition the dropship and you'd be
trying to do things where you're
actually man you forget if you're
manufacturing is occurring outside Italy
if distribution occurs outside Italy
then you know your customers are outside
Italy guess what you can keep going here
but you know this remember this
days will pass where a country's on
lockdown but they trying to do right now
is stop the speed of transmission not so
that people won't get it
people everyone's gonna get it alright
come on I've heard from very very well
informed sources doctors experts in
epidemiology all right they expect
anywhere from forty to seventy percent
of the human population to eventually
get coronavirus not in this novel
version number nineteen right why
because nobody has natural community and
it's highly contagious what they're
trying to do that was slower the spread
of the virus so it's not to overwhelm
the health care systems because here's
the deal most people that get this are
gonna be just fine it's for people that
are young it barely affects them at all
people in their twenties thirties no big
problem there are some complications
especially if you have some health
complications before for the most part
generally speaking it's not a death
sentence for people that get into 20s
30s and 40s or 50s even right we're you
get your sixties and seventies
especially a compromise in some way you
got a serious chance of it becoming
either fatal or cup requiring serious
hospitalization intervention and being
intubated
perhaps there's you know support needed
for your kidneys and your heart whatever
that might be
what they can't afford right now is for
all the cases that come in at once so
what they trying to do here slow down
the transmission not stop it slow down
the transmission so the healthcare
system can deal with it over time versus
all at once it will collapse the system
and the people that really need care
most older people immune cotton-like
pregnant women
I think I'm personal too right if they
all everyone's rushing in at once
there's not enough tubes to go around
the incubate people if you want more
advice wisdom guidance from other
successful entrepreneurs on how you can
navigate the coronavirus situation check
out the video right there next
I hope you find it valuable continue to
believe and I'll see you there if you're
just in an apartment you can still do
all of they jumping jacks or